[Music]
hey everybody well I haven't recorded a
whole lot lately in the last few days
and that's just because not a whole lot
interesting has happened so uh kind of
hard to find interesting
things so anyways it's I don't even know
what today is Tuesday it must be tues no
oh it's Monday sorry today's Monday
yikes that's what you get for being a
farmer not knowing what day of the week
it is anyways so we're just coming back
from town
I had a package at the post office and
more
importantly I have a
tube for a sprinkler tire that I'm going
to put back on well I done messed
up I have I have put tubes in so many of
these
tires and I have never had this
happen obviously I made a mistake but
somehow I got the tube wedged between
the tire and the
rail and I can't get them I'm to the
point now where it's like I cannot get
that stuffed in so I decided okay well
whatever I'll take the tire back
apart so I did I got this side off which
is the last side I put
on uh but the wheel is it's wedged in
there
hard
and I know there's a way to get it apart
but um if I am not careful I will get
stressed out and I'm going to end up
just cutting this whole tire in half to
get it off and I don't think I don't
think we need that kind of violence
today so we're going to let this project
sit I'm going to cool off mentally and
literally cuz it's hot in
[Music]
here
and we'll see what I decide to do with
that I won I beat the system
technically I
cheated
um I I finally got the I put some blocks
over I jumped on the tire got it popped
off and I was able to get
the uh I ended up I was going to try and
just push the tube the rest of the way
in once it was loose but then I found a
spot where I had put a hole in the tube
and
decided you know what we're just going
to take the tube off and see if it holds
so I took the tube out the main reason
we put tubes in these tires is because
when the wheel is in the pivot track the
sides of the when it's sunk down a
little bit the sides of the track push
in on the side of the tire and can
squeeze on that sidewall and that's
where a lot of our tires have come off
um is because of that and if you put a
tube in it helps support that and it
doesn't really matter sometimes if that
sidewall gets pushed in a little bit cuz
there's a tube in there
um but we've done it this way plenty of
times this is how we used to always do
it and this how we're going to do it
today cuz I won a few days
later not a whole lot happened that was
interesting at
least but we've got some rain coming for
the next few days
and we've got a couple crops that need
cut the grass
field and we actually have a field of
millet that's getting pretty
close so we need to get this machine
ready to
go um I got a hay buyer coming pretty
quick so we're going to jump in this
move it over to the shop where it can be
worked
on
and we'll load this person with hay
and we'll get
going so that's
that see you in a
minute we sharpened all the blades got
those ready to go put a put a nice
shiny nice shiny Edge on those you know
it's not
perfect but we'll get a lot more life
out of them assuming they don't get hit
by a rock which most of the time that's
what brings them to an end very very
rarely do we uh there's not really a
whole lot of rocks out there it's
just I don't know it's hard to explain
for some reason it seems to be pretty
rare when we actually wear these down to
the point of
replacement they usually break so at
least in this country anyways we got
that done we went through and checked
the oil checked all the all the
oils
and the
filters blew out all the air filters
there's the engine there's the cab
filter check the oil the engine oil the
I don't even know what you call it crank
case oil I'm guessing is what it's
called I don't I don't know I'm not a
mechanic don't judge me
I'm a YouTube Certified
mechanic well that started shutting hard
for some reason we still got to give it
a bath but I'm we're not going to be
using this wind rower for a few days cuz
it's supposed to rain for about four or
5 days
straight um so I have time I have time
to give her a bath um where's this
handle there we
go and hydraulic oils good
good there's not a whole lot to check on
this side except remind myself when I
did the filters um I actually need to
look on my chart and see how many hours
this machine has run since I did this
oil
change airbags don't leak yet on our old
one they did horribly you had to air
them up every single time you went out
it was
annoying and these do a really good job
I love this machine so much it does such
a good job
the only
thing the only thing I don't like about
it is
that the newer machines I don't know if
you'll be able to tell let's get
underneath here I don't know what you
call that sometimes I call it a
baffle but anyways that's what I adjust
up and down to determine how wide the
wind row is that doesn't actually make
sense to me I don't get how adjusting
that Up and Down Changes the width of
the wind R but it absolutely does much
more than these
do
um but my only issue is that it doesn't
do it very evenly so the sides always
have more there's always more hay on the
edge and there's in the
middle and on the newer machines the new
New Holland and the new K the the plus
series I think cuz this is
the let's see this is the 419 just just
the 419 momax 2 I guess or the durine
durine 419 and on the 49
plus cuz we demoed
one last year two years ago and
the I'm calling it the bath
hole um has on the bottom all these
little adjustable um guides or veins
that's what they are I guess these
adjustable veins that you can adjust
manually to get a more even wind row and
I've heard they work extremely well I've
seen some videos but I I've also heard
that Massie Fergusons work really good
too the newer ones at least
um
so I don't know that's my only
disgruntle with
this I would still prefer this over
Massie Ferguson purely because in our
circumstance this 19t head is absolutely
amazing
that is that is really nice it works
really nice with our rake really nice
with the Bor especially on
Alfalfa you get done a lot quicker with
all these
fields and then of course I put the
aftermarket Trimble in there um cuz I
can't stand the pro
700 worst monitor ever created
but case's new monitor I haven't gotten
to try it but I've heard it works really
nice
and we're just putting the
shield but it looks really nice looks
much more user friendly than the pro 700
so we have we've had a few Pro 700s and
they
just I don't like
them
but I have there is still a pro 7 wealth
I guess it's called The intell View
because it's New Holland there is still
an intell view monitor in there
uh and that's just to run the
machine cuz I need to be able to
see all the machine data so all the
machine data runs on this monitor all
the GPS functions run on this
Monitor
and man it works so nice and with this
we get a a the the RTX it's like 400
bucks a year super cheap as compared to
I don't know maybe you can get RTX on
these too I I don't know but for the
same price but anyways this when we ran
GPS here if you didn't have a
subscription it's useless GPS on this is
useless without a subscription unless
you're going in straight
lines um but the subscription for this
monitor was like $2,000 some dollars a
year and we quit doing that cuz we're
not planting as much corn as we used to
so it didn't become
and just in our situation in general
it's not as important to us as it used
to be so we still need the accuracy I
use that that monitor and the nav 900
they go on our other tractor in the
spring but don't really need it during
the summer so anyways we got this all
done probably not today but maybe
tomorrow I'll give this guy a
bath
and I think I think that'll about do it
today um I was working
on yesterday this is an air dryer off
one of our
trucks and I've recently learned that
you're supposed to replace these filters
this is just an air filter I
guess and so Grandpa went and picked one
up but it's the wrong this is the ad IP
and this is for the
adsp um
and then of course this is the purge
valve uh that's what this box is for
this is the filter but wrong fil wrong
wrong dryer is what this is for so I got
to take this back probably
tomorrow and then who knows I might do
it today we'll see how I feel after
lunch but it's just it's a really long
drive
so anyways I guess that's it that's
probably going to be it for today
and I'll get back to you tomorrow or
whenever something interesting
happens well we've got a ourselves a fun
new
project we are I got the
loader I got the loader in the shop
here
um I already went through and relieved
all the pressure off of
the the boom and everything else that I
could find
and these lines although I think I'm
going to do it on the other side there's
this is one of the lift cylinders and
these are the two lines going into
it
um we'll zoom out a little bit there we
go
and this is the other side and this is
where I'm actually going to do this at
so we are putting a scale on this loader
we're going to try that out and see
see how well that works sounds like a
good idea so
um kind of did a did a poll with some of
our customers and they all said that it
would be really nice if we had a scale
so I have to take these two connections
off because the way this scale works is
they they plug in a pressure
transducer into the lift cylinder and it
needs the pressure off the lift
cylinder to determine the weight after
it's been calibrated but I have to take
these off and figure out not only what
type of connection they are but also um
what size and I'm not an expert in
hydraulic
connections so uh I'm going to do some
research I'm going to go eat breakfast
and while I'm doing that I'm going to do
some research on exactly how to figure
out what type and what size it is we'll
pop these off take some measurements and
get it sent
in and then the way it'll work is there
will be some sort of a computer
apparatus that I don't know where I'm
going to mount it yet maybe somewhere
like right here or somewhere it's got to
be I want it somewhere where it's not
going to get it's got to be on the front
of the frame cuz I I want it ahead of
the pivot
point so I don't know where the best
place to put it is maybe on the inside
that might be a good spot actually we'll
have to see make sure that's it's not
going to get too close to anything but I
don't think it
will um so we'll do that and then
that'll send a wireless signal to a
tablet I'm still got to replace that
window to a tablet that is mounted up
there and um that's how we measure the
weight so that'll be a from Project we
won't actually get it for a few weeks
they said it takes a little while to
order in my SP
and and to get them set up but once we
do get it installed this will be a
pretty fun little apparatus so I'm going
to go eat breakfast and we'll come back
to this so I forgot to video of the
whole process but we popped one of these
off they're both the same we popped one
of these off and I took a bunch of
measurements uh did some research online
to figure out turns out this is a I've
never heard heard of this again I'm not
an expert but it's called a D connector
is the
style and I guess they're all in metric
which would make sense anyways took the
measurements and now we're going to go
over to the house and send those in an
email so the scale company can get the
scale sent this
way in today's Deep dive we dive deep
I thought that was pretty good anyways
um got a lot of stuff taken
apart I know I was talking about putting
the scale on here the other
day and I mean got all that figured out
actually there's a new place where that
scale is going to go and let me get my
flashlight
here so we've actually decided oh boy
boy are you going to focus there we go
so we've actually
decided that
[Music]
down oh you're not going to be able to
see it from here but there's some line
some hoses run across the bottom some
line steel lines and it's a lot more
protected under
there than cuz I called the company and
I was like hey I don't I don't know how
much I actually want Electronics hanging
out right here cuz I know how much junk
builds up there in the
winter and I asked him if it was okay if
we put it inside inside of here with all
the
other stuff that's protected and he said
that was fine
so the reason this is tore AP apart and
the steps are on the ground and
everything which I only have about an
hour to get this put back together cuz
we got hay a hay chart coming is because
the parking brake doesn't
work and well I should say works period
doesn't function the way it's supposed
to and
the the ride control which is the boom
suspension uh also doesn't work now that
I have never gotten that to even start
to work so I don't know that's its own
separate issue I haven't figured that
one out yet but the parking brake these
are the the nitrogen accumulators I
guess you call it
and they run the parking brake I believe
they're also supposed to run the boom
suspension the parking brake
itself operates let's see if I can turn
this light on
here the parking brake
itself is that little green lever
sticking
out and you can see I have the linkage
unhooked for a very good reason because
anytime the parking brake it it goes to
it it um what do you call
that it
defaults to parking brake engaged on
this machine so what that means is that
any time if the parking brake doesn't
work it's
engaged and you can't
move so I unhooked the linkage and that
will not get hooked back
up until I can solve the problem because
what happens is you're driving along I
got it to it started working um last
year it started working suddenly and so
I got it all hooked back up excited and
it worked fine for about 2 weeks and
then all of a sudden both when me and
Grandpa were both at different times
driving this
machine it was both when we were backing
up thankfully and I always wear my seat
Bel but you know grandpa
doesn't and we were backing up parking
brake engages oh my gosh when I tell you
it feels like you got in a car wreck
goodness
gracious immediately I unhooked it I was
like I'm not playing that game that's
dumb So the plan is I
can I've determined it's it has to be
electrical I don't get it cuz what'll
happen is like you'll hit the parking
brake button and test and various and
this and that and all of a sudden just
stops
working
so it's I'm pretty sure it's
electrical I haven't figured out what
about it I don't understand what I don't
know I'm not an
engineer guys so I know down behind here
is the actual valve and the solenoid
itself I was kind of thinking it might
be the
solenoid and I was going to take that
off and then check it but then I started
realizing that if this whole system is
under pressure I don't know if I want to
take this illinoid
out I mean if it's safe to do
so I might just have to call
Volvo um and get advice from
them
but that's where we're at now kind of to
the point where I just got to get this
back together real
quick at least good enough to go we'll
see I can get in the cab without the
steps on and if I load the truck
that's okay we'll see we'll see what I
do I got everything greased up yesterday
as well I greased everything on this
machine crawled underneath did all the
drive shafts all
that at some point I need to check these
planetaries that hasn't been done in a
really long time and really needs done
so we're going to get to work I'm going
to get this put back
together and we'll get it out of here
and ready to go